well I mean lots going on okay well how
are you feeling I'm good I mean I would
be lying if I said that I'm not upset
but I think that's a natural feeling and
I think it'll subside in a few days
hopefully with the help of some alcohol
but other than that I mean it is what it
is it's a game and I knew coming into it
it was a long shot but regardless I'm so
grateful to have played Johnny insisted
you were a pawn and I know that you
never really believed or be trusted when
did you feel like the tide was turning
there I do feel that I lost control
actually hours before the eviction I do
know that gala did their last attempt
plea in the middle of the night the
night before and I kind of swore on
family members and basically offered up
their firstborn child and basically just
wanted to solidify that they weren't
going to go after them I knew it was all
a ploy yeah I didn't find out until too
late and ultimately I wasn't willing to
do the same I didn't feel it was
necessary I felt like my loyalty spoke
more volume than that but apparently I
was wrong
well I mean like you were spearheading
the attempt to save Johnny so are you
reading it but how are you feeling about
did you regret it immediately
I like to think I don't have any regrets
in this game because everything I did I
really like dissected it I really tried
to think of every potential scenario but
there's just too many variables to ever
predict what may or may not happen in
the moment it felt like the right
decision shortly after that house
meeting he called I started to regret it
but I didn't want to focus on regret I
wanted to just deal with what I had in
front of me and move forward and try and
make whatever was coming my way work are
the new game moves though that you you
know looking back and of course having
like a full evening of reflection that
you would have done differently yeah I
think not saving Johnny
it would have been definitely one that I
would have done ultimately I don't know
if I feel like I would have wound up in
a similar situation but I think without
Johnny there I may have had the votes to
stay I think Johnny's campaigning for
Kayla to go probably came off as the
fact that he was trying to keep me which
may have scared the other trio thinking
that Johnny Liv and I would be a force
moving forward
but ultimately I think that Johnny was
strategic in choosing me as his
replacement nominee over Olivia it spoke
volumes to me at this stage in the game
you don't put up anyone that you
potentially may fear losing because you
have to know that the house flips
constantly so for me when he put me up
it was that's where my suspicions came
that maybe there was a deeper intent and
not putting up Matty or putting up
Olivia even it it's said to me I'm okay
to gamble with your game if the house
does slip and you go home I'm okay with
that so it was a bit of a slap in the
face because he will see it when he
watches back I really did spearhead his
survival in that game so do you think
that that's gonna affect him in any way
I do think that me leaving will affect
him ultimately at this stage in the game
I was going to keep my word to him until
I couldn't anymore I was going to take
him out at the next opportunity but I
don't necessarily think that would have
been right away and I think he would
have had numbers with me and loyalty
with me I think the targets for everyone
was a trio and the showmance
and I think that we could have gone
farther in this game but ultimately now
I feel he only has Olivia and it'll be
interesting to see who follows yeah not
you know you said Liv was kinda like
you're your rock and be like you're
obviously still looking for her I am
100% rooting for my girl my ding dong I
know the game she's playing because we
were playing the same game a lot of the
things that we did or kind of
masterminded if you will we did together
so I know the ins and outs of her game
of course I try not to be biased so if
somebody else can tell me specifically
how they maneuver through the game and I
find it to be better then I will
consider it but as of right now she's
got my vote I think it's fair to say
that you and Ryan are not the best of
friends you know um I'm really excited
to see Ryan actually as a person I love
everybody in the house I want an
opportunity to explain myself with to
Ryan because I actually am really
feeling what he felt I feel as though
the house was set in one direction and I
kind of was the reason it flipped
and I feel like the house flipped on me
last minute so I want an opportunity to
explain myself to him and what my
thought process was I'm hoping that will
alleviate maybe some of his frustrations
and I also can't wait to hear kind of
his view and his take on everything
that's happened up until this point and
maybe we can compare notes and you know
he and I still have a lot of power yeah
kind of mastermind who wins depending on
who comes in next right so who do you
think will come in next I'm really
really freaking hoping it's Paris Paris
or well yeah I feel I think I feel the
most betrayed by them again there was
always a lot of doubts between Paris and
I throughout the game I'm sure people
noticed that but ultimately she did pull
up my heartstrings you know the little
sister big sister vibe we fought like
sisters but we also loved each other
like sisters and I really ultimately
felt that that would outweigh any lie or
anything that Kayla would say she looks
me many times in the eye and said I
would choose you over Kayla and she
didn't will said he had my back since
day one and I saved him and now when the
roles were reversed and he had the
opportunity to save me he didn't
so I'm salty and I really want both of
them to walk in right behind me yeah
yeah I was just gonna say you know it
feels like emotions are still running
pretty high they are I think that's to
be expected and ultimately I know it
will subside in a few days but right now
I just have so many unanswered questions
and you have to know that when you're in
that house you literally live breathe
eat everything the game and that's all
you know that's your entire world so
when it feels like it's been snatched
away from you it's like a really bad
breakup and there's no closure so I need
some closure so I think once I get that
I'll be able to move on are you looking
forward to the opportunity to maybe
extract some sweet sweet revenge
absolutely yeah absolutely I mean if I I
want to be one of the jurors that gets
to ask a question cuz I want to put them
in the hot seat I want to give a little
sass and I really want to make them earn
my vote